i have three word problems here what i
want to do in in this video is not solve
the word problems but just set up the
equation that we could solve to get the
answer to the word problems and
essentially we're going to be setting up
proportions in either case so in this
first problem we have nine markers cost
eleven dollars and fifty cents and then
they ask us how much would seven markers
cost and let's just set x to be equal to
our answer so x is equal to the cost
of seven markers
the cost of seven markers so the way to
solve a problem like this is to set up
two ratios and then set them equal to
each other so you could say that the
ratio of nine markers to the cost of
nine markers so the ratio of the number
of markers so nine to the cost of the
nine markers to 1150
1150 this should be equal to the ratio
of our new number of markers
seven
equal to the new number of markers so
that's 7
to whatever the new cost or whatever the
cost of 7 markers are
to x so let me do x in green 2
2x so this is a completely valid
proportion here the ratio of of the of
nine markers to the cost of nine markers
is equal to seven markers to the cost of
seven markers and then you could solve
this to figure out how much those seven
markers would cost and you could flip
both sides of this it would still be a
completely valid ratio you could have
eleven fifty
eleven fifty to nine so the ratio
between the cost of nine mark the
ratio between the cost of the markers to
the number of markers you're buying is
equal to so 11 59 is equal to
the cost of seven markers is equal to
seven markers
is the is equal to the ratio of the cost
of seven markers to the number of
markers which is obviously seven so all
i would do is flip
both sides of this equation right here
to get this one over here you could also
think about you could also think about
the ratios in other ways you could say
that the ratio
the ratio of
nine markers to seven markers the ratio
of nine markers to seven markers is
going to be the same as the ratio of
their cost is going to be the ratio is
going to be equal to the ratio of the
cost of nine markers to the cost of
seven markers and then obviously you
could flip both of these sides so you
could say that the ratio of seven
markers
then the same magenta color the ratio of
seven markers to nine markers is the
same thing as the ratio of the cost of
seven markers to the cost of nine
markers so that is 1150. so all of these
would be valid proportions valid
equations that describe what's going on
here and then you could you would just
have to essentially solve for x so let's
do this one right over here seven apples
cost five dollars
how many apples can i buy with eight
dollars so once again we can say so
we're going to assume that what they're
asking is you know how many apples how
many apples let's call that x
x is what we want to solve for so seven
apples cost five dollars so we have the
ratio between the number of apples
seven and the cost of the apples five is
going to be equal to is going to be
equal to the ratio between another
number of apples which is now x which is
now x and the cost of that other number
of apples
and it's going to be eight dollars and
so notice here in this first situation
what was unknown was the cost so we kind
of had the number of apples to cost
number of apples to cost now in this
example the the unknown is the number of
apples so number of apples to cost
number of apples to cost and we could do
all of the different scenarios like this
you could also say the ratio between the
ratio between seven apples and x apples
is going to be the same as the ratio
between the cost of
the cost of seven apples and the cost of
eight apples
and and obviously you could flip both
sides of these in either of these
equations to get two more equations and
any of these would be valid would be
valid equations now let's do this last
one
so we have a cake recipe for five people
i'll use new colors here a cake recipe
for five people
requires two eggs
it requires two eggs
how many eggs so we want to know how
many eggs so this will call x and you
don't always have to call it x you could
call it e for a well e isn't a good idea
because e represents another number once
you get to higher mathematics but you
could call them you could call them y or
z or any variable a b or c anything how
many eggs do we need for a 15 person
cake how many eggs do we need for a 15
person cake so you could say the ratio
of people to eggs so the ratio of people
to eggs is constant so if we have five
people
for two eggs
then
for 15 people
then for 15 people we are going to need
x eggs this ratio is going to be
constant 5 over 2 is equal to 15 over x
or you could flip both sides of this or
you could say the ratio between 5
and 15 the ratio between 5 and 15 is
going to be equal to the ratio between
the number of eggs for five people
let me do that in that blue color
the ratio between the number of eggs for
five people and the ratio of the and and
the number of eggs for 15 people and
obviously you could flip both sides of
this equation so all of these we've
essentially set up the proportions that
describe each of these each of these
problems and then you can go later and
solve for x to actually get the answer